and we are really excited to have dr
anshu bharathwaj with us uh who would be
talking about understanding uh and
addressing genotype phenotype
correlation in complex diseases as we
have been discussing dr anshu bharatwaj
is a biologist and a data scientist she
has obtained her phd in 2008 in
understanding of genotypic phenotypic
correlation in human mitochondrial
diseases from csir ccmb hyderabad she
has over 40 publications to her credit
and have trained over 500 young students
and also has served as an associate
scientific advisor for science uh
for science translational medicine and
is on the editorial board of journal of
genetics and frontiers of system biology
protein bioinformatics computational
genomics and f 1000 research galaxy
gateway where
many of our students have already
published some of these
some of these articles that they have
worked on so we are really delighted to
have you dr anshu bharatwaj and we are
looking forward to your presentation and
learn from your talk thank you over to
you ma'am
thank you
so much for that introduction so
can you hear me clearly
yes yes
all right
uh are my slides visible
yeah they're coming up yeah they're
visible now
all right so first of all thanks for
giving me the opportunity uh
to actually talk to students that's my
you know that's that's my lifeline
so what i decided today since the entire
symposium is organized around
bioinformatics and data science training
and research i have kept the talk very
very simple but we have included one
component of our work so that you can
also see the application of how it can
be done again in the most simplest
possible fashion
so
my lab
primarily
works in two domains one is basically
genotype phenotype correlations
when it comes to
infectious diseases as well as
mitochondrial diseases and the second
vertical which is a smaller component is
computational drug discovery
so
just a second so as you can see here uh
there are several projects that we have
done over years but today i have
selected projects which are on the
bottom panel of this timeline which is
mostly to do with mitochondrial diseases
because i thought genomics is something
which is basically picking up the base
so it's important that we understand the
genomics basics in terms of where are we
going where do we stand today
so as we all know dna is the blueprint
of life and one of the first
uh
objectives is to actually learn to read
this dna right that was the first thing
we started doing because till the time
we read what is in the blueprint we
cannot make sense out of it right
so in early sequencing days in like
1960s the first rna sequence which is of
alanine trna was sequenced it took five
people for three years working to
determine just 76 nucleotides so this is
how we started sequencing we were not
sequencing genomes in the in the
beginning we were trying to standardize
the technology to understand how you
read this and subsequently over years we
started taking
like baby steps where we went ahead from
that to one base per month
then to a thousand bases per day and by
the time we sequence the human genome we
were already doing 10 million bases per
day
right
and till that time is when you know we
actually this is a quiz for kids who
would like to enter their answers um to
say what this event is so this is
basically a landmark event in the
history of current biotechnology and
data sciences is when we launched the
draft of the human genome project right
and this is the big machine that at that
point was used to sequence it
it took effort from several countries
and a very large number of sequencing
centers to give us the first draft of
the human genome sequence which was 23
human chromosomes with 3 billion bases
right
why were we interested in sequencing
simple reason to understand human
disease and evolution if you can compare
the genome sequence of somebody who is
diseased versus somebody who is normal
the uh
anticipation was that we will be able to
understand diseases better at a
molecular level and if you can some if
you can understand something better it
is easier to treat it so as the previous
speaker was referring to a large number
of methods for this kind of data
analysis the objective is very clear
that you need to understand human
disease and evolution and that is why
there was an intense amount of effort
put into place
but this was only a project where you
were trying to understand and
standardize the technology and then we
went ahead from this basic sequencing
methods to something we understand as
next generation
sequencing methods
and with the advent of ngs
now there are a very large number of
sequencing projects going on across the
world where a few countries are actually
sequence their entire population so
these sequencing efforts actually have
gone uh the scalability is unimaginable
we are generating data at a base and we
don't really know how to analyze it so
that is where the power of data sciences
lies in
it is very critical right now for
students who have disabled who are
basically deciding on uh
you know a research objective try to
learn data analysis because you actually
have a lot of data available that needs
to be analyzed in context of what is now
dizzy associated among all this plethora
of sequence that you see
and the starting resource that i would
recommend to all of you is genomic so
genome aggregation database is trying to
aggregate all the genome sequencing
projects at one place so you don't have
to wander around several places for this
kind of data so you can go to genome
media for that reference
now when you say you are trying to
compare individuals with and without
disease what are we trying to compare or
what are we trying to look at we are
trying to come back at a point where we
can look at genomic variations right
now genomic variations can be of several
types the most common ones are single
nucleotide polymorphism these are called
in general language substitutions
we will read more about them in the next
slide then there are indents which is
insertion deletions and they can
actually change the protein function
then there are structural variations
then there are tandem repeat variations
segmental duplications translocation and
most of us in our undergrad or in
masters must have come across these
terminologies where these actually are
impacting the way the chromosome is or
the sequences arranged in uh in an order
and then when that arrangement goes here
you do you expect to see um that there
can be a disease for phenotype
now when you talk of single nucleotide
polymorphism it means that its a
variation at a single nucleotide say for
example
let us say there is a gene a and that
gene a has an exon right we all know
what exons are
in exon one at some position let us say
500 in a population you either see a or
c
now in technical terms we call alleles
at the nuclear level so there is an ale
and there is a
now let's say a is the most commonly
like 90 percent of uh of the times the
thus like a is observed so we call it as
a major alley
and c is observed the rest 10 percent of
the time so it's a minor array
so since humans are deployed we get one
pair of chromosomes from our mother the
other from the father
then so basically what you actually will
see is that either the individuals will
have a a
ac or cc right at this particular
position
now how do you decide that it is an snp
is when the minor allele and in this
case that is c is present at a frequency
of more than one percent in the
population
so let's take two examples in the first
case if 94 people have c which is the
major elite and six percent happy which
is a minor le you say this as an snp
in the other case if you see a similar
situation
but the percentage of the minor allele
is not even one percent that you start
calling it a mutation
now this you need to understand is
heavily context dependent
the reason being that if you are looking
at rare variation then this definition
will change
and that is one has to now look at
single nucleotide polymorphism
definition or with or genomic variation
in context of what you are trying to
look for and obviously when you are
looking for rare variants you need to
sequence a very very large number of
individuals and then of course when both
the maternal and the paternal allele are
same that's an homozygous snp when they
are different it's a heterozygous symbol
and they are present everywhere like
they can be in utrs introns right side
they can be encoding regions where they
may or may not change the amino acid in
most in almost all these cases they
might have an impact on the phenotype
now the question that you might ask is
that you sequence an individual sequence
another individual so one person has
disease x the other person does not have
disease x just compare the sequence and
you are good to go right you can now
actually identify the differences and
say this is what is causing the disease
it is not that simple and that is where
what we are discussing today
any complex disease is not happening
because of a single genomic variant
there are many genomic variants which we
call as polygenic
in interaction with the environmental
factors are actually causing the
phenotype in this case i have shown the
example of coronary artery disease
so complex disorders i must repeat this
because this is a very very important
factor
results from contributions of
multiple genomic variants
and genes and that is why they are
called as polygenic and they work in
conjunction with the physical and the
social environment to bring out the
phenotype and this is the challenge we
are trying to now resolve
when you compare to individuals you will
get anywhere between three to five
million snps which are different
which of those snps are associated with
the disease that's the first question
second which of them might cause the
disease there can be several reasons why
the disease is manifested
and that is where the challenge lies in
order to
address this challenge
there are two basic approach that
approaches that are applied one we call
it as a candidate gene approach the
other one is a genome wide association
studies and we'll very quickly look at
both of them what do you mean by
candidate gene approach
so in a candidate gene approach what you
actually are doing you are basically
making an intelligent guess like say for
example you are interested to identify a
genetic risk factor for a particular
disease condition which is a complex
disease
and you now need to know what are the
genes contributing to this phenotype so
that you can now look at the variation
in those genes
now this mostly is done within family
members or it can also be unrelated
cases
but the point is you need to have some
estimate
of what kind of biological
components might be involved say for
example i have taken an example here
if you are studying alcoholism why some
people are getting addicted to alcohol
and you want to know the genetic
components of that
the most logical choices would be to
look at their alcohol
metabolic pathways and
particular genes like alcohol
dehydrogenase or aldehyde dehydrogenase
these are logical options for you to
start
and if you do see that there are several
alleles of this genes in the population
making it a very strong case that you
now know that they are actually very
among individuals now you can actually
apply a candidate gene approach
start looking for variation only in
these set of genes and then identify
polymorphism which might be associated
to the disease
and subsequently establishing why this
might also cause the disease so here you
are actually also digging deep into the
mechanism of what that variation might
be doing
the problem is in most cases this kind
of educated guess either has failed or
it is extremely difficult to make and
that is where genome-wide associations
are association studies are done where
you are actually following a very
data-driven approach you take two
cohorts two groups of individuals one
normal for the phenotype the other one
actually has the phenotype and when i
say phenotype i am saying the disease
and then you sequence them compare
identify snps and then start looking for
association
of these snps with the disease phenotype
now the word associated is kept or we
know very categorically here reason is
association is not equal to causation
you may find snps which are associated
with the disease they might not be
causing the disease as such so jivas
actually will help you
identify at least shortlist those
candidates and then explore them deeper
with respect to what is their role
in disease manifestation
several studies have actually there are
many many jivas that have been done till
date and do we do have some success
stories where if you look at this
publication they actually have listed
several traits
against which genes were identified
using jivas and they ultimately actually
allowed discovery of
drug candidates to treat these diseases
so we do have success stories in these
methods work obviously the number of
jeepas that has been performed versus
the outcome is
not comparable so we need more
intelligent methods of doing that and
maybe a better readout
so what actually uh is going on right
now is there is a
very big effort going on to catalog
genomic variation
of different populations all across the
world and then also trying to assess
which of these genomic variation
might have a clinical implication so
there is if you look at i have listed a
few papers from last uh two to three
years some of them are old like clinvar
but clinvar keeps updating very
regularly then there is a genomatic
100k project but some of them are very
new as new as this month so i would
recommend that you actually read these
publications it will give you in context
of what is really going on
how are these genomic variations
documented and analyzed and why do you
need these kind of resources when you
actually have a reference you know so
you actually reference you know is just
uh
it's like 70 percent one individual's
readout despite the fact that when the
genome sequence was done they were like
people sample of 20 individuals but it
is mostly laid out from one
individual so it's not really
representative of how diverse we are and
that is why you need to sequence from
various populations in different
contexts
now for today i have kept a very simple
example of what we did in our lab and
i'll be very quickly describing that so
you need to focus because i'll very very
quickly finish this
so our lab has been interested
to understand what is the role of
mitochondrial dna in human diseases and
if you look at the this is i've just
shown a representation of mitochondria
if you look at the
electron transport chain it has five
complexes the ones which are shown in
green are encoded by nuclear dna the
ones which are shown by red are included
by mitochondrial dna it is not very
difficult to make a judgment that there
has to be a very
intense crosstalk between the two
genomes for mitochondria to function
properly
and it is not just the energy metabolism
uh mitochondria is involved in
practically all central metabolic
pathways in the cell making it an
extremely critical organelle and given
that this organelle has its own dna
makes it a very strong case to look at
what mutations in mitochondrial dna
might lead to disease uh
uh phenotypes now one of the things not
everybody understands the structure of
mitochondrial dna so i have kept a very
small introduction it's a circular
molecule it is 16 kb in size it is
mostly maternally inherited there are
two rnas 22 trnas and 13 protein coding
genes in mitochondrial dna a single
non-coding region which is d-loop and
over 3000 other proteins are required
for mitochondria to function properly
which are encoded by nuclear dna right
and there is a very very big repertoire
of genome sequence data available across
different populations that one can use
to now look at disease association
context of
mitochondrial diseases
the problem with genotype phenotype
correlation in mitochondria is that when
you actually see these point mutations
the symptoms manifest in many many
different ways making it very difficult
to understand uh or establish
pathogenicity of a change in
mitochondria and that is where
we developed an algorithm which we
called as bit snp score it was published
long time back
and the objective is how do you
score variation
for the disease association again i am
not talking of causation here so it's
very important that i keep using the
word association again and again
and comparison is performed against
normal data sets so i'll very quickly
show you what we did
so first things first was
i needed to understand which kind of
mutations in mitochondria
have an experimental evidence that this
actually might cause the disease so that
was my first objective is to first list
out
reported biochemical defects which are
like low complex activities or
functional studies which are done using
trans mitochondrial hybrids to establish
that some of these mutations are
actually causing the disease are not
just associated with them
use them as a basis
to select which tools are good to now
select these kind of variations from the
plethora of other variation that i see
and then subsequently i design a
scoring scheme which i will not have
time to explain today
but the whole point is if a variant is
of very little importance it was given a
score of one
if it is of very you know if it is
really causing a problem with
mitochondrial replication for example it
is given a score of 10.
so between this 1 and 10 the other
scores as you have seen here are
assigned based on the
anticipated impact that these mutations
or might have on the mitochondrial
function
and then when you actually have several
such mutations in an individual we
multiply all the scores and not add them
so this is the and logic i would request
you to go and read the paper on why we
applied this logic it's very interesting
and once we did that and the pipeline
was ready
we actually applied it on patient data
sets
which are ataxia and met snp and we
applied it on almost 600 individuals
uh which are both having metabolic as
well as
neurodegenerative cases okay
for normal sequences we use the context
dependent normal for indian ataxia
patients we used the indian normal data
for japanese
disease individuals we used japanese
centenarians so that the background
variation effect is not there and
centenarians were an extremely good
control set because these are people who
were 100 years old and they were
absolutely healthy which means
any mutation in these
individuals might not be causing the
disease by themselves
so when we applied this whole uh
algorithm on the 600 plus individuals
whose you know mitochondrial dna
datasets
we could actually prioritize only 304
percent of total variations
it's not 5 or 600 between any two
individuals we actually could prioritize
very very small set
and obviously we also were able to
identify novel variations in some genes
which were not reported before so it was
very interesting to see that the method
was working and we were able to identify
some noble variants which were not even
deported by that time
ah so basically this is a new uh this
actually still is something which most
methods cannot do
ah one observation we made back then was
that
rare variants are high scoring variance
as opposed to the general understanding
that common variants are disease
associated we didn't observe that even
at that point and now there are more and
more papers who are actually trying to
scout for rare variations for
disassociation so this is one of the
first studies where we could actually
observe this and reported it and we
could find noble disease associated
variants with this application
moving forward again i will not be able
to describe much of this work but since
you know that in each
cell there are several mitochondria and
within each mitochondria there are
several mitochondrial dna
and we could actually assess this
mitochondrial dna for disease
association
the second logical thing was to now look
at more than 3000 proteins which were
quoted by nuclear dna but have a
mitochondrial function to see the
holistic impact of variation in an
individual
both for nuclear and mitochondrial dna
for digit association studies
now here we used several resources to
identify which nuclear
encoded proteins have mitochondrial
function
and just bear with me on this slide for
a minute
so if you look at the left hand panel we
utilized several resources
to identify
nuclear encoded proteins with
mitochondrial function
identified which of the mutations in
these proteins actually have been
reported to be pathogenic in clinvar
which means they are clinically
actionable
and mapped these variations onto the
genome asia 100k project which actually
also has data on almost 600 individuals
from india
we then took all these uh mapping where
you actually found this and can map this
to this generate data which is genes and
variations associated to human disease
so we could generate a mitochondrial
gene disease in network
and in this network we could also
identify loss of function variations
from genomic datasets if some of you
actually find it difficult to follow in
this presentation you can always
write back to me because there is a lot
of background information one needs to
know to understand this
the logic that you need to understand is
what we are trying to do we were trying
to see whether
pathogenic variations reported for the
rest of the world
are they also pathogenic or are they
also loss of function in these
in the asian subcontinent or
particularly for indian population or
not
what we actually observe that is that
that one needs to perform population
specific mapping of clinically relevant
variation we cannot rely on a loss of
function variation data coming from the
rest of the world to our population
because we don't see that happening
so this is very important now that one
has to generate population specific
references
and population specific variation data
which might not be reported actually for
the rest of the world because they are
not yellow there but they can be here so
this is a very important message and
this recently was also endorsed by
genome media in the recent paper where
they actually say the same thing
now one of the things that one can do
with this kind of platform is you can
study commodities because now it's a
network we are saying may be one disease
and several genes and one gene and
several disables so this is something
that we are looking at and particularly
from indian population context
when we did enrichment analysis we could
see that certain pathways like defects
in vitamin and co-factor metabolism pr
investigation
dna repair pathways these are very very
important to study in asian population
context
so this is the first platform that we
have identified to look at comorbidities
i didn't actually focus it from a
co-operative perspective because it
requires a little bit more background to
uh
you know understand it at a more
detailed level but if any one of you are
already working on this kind of strategy
we have actually provided all of this
resource as a workflow system in galaxy
so no programming experience is required
if you have a question you can come on
this platform and generate all your own
custom workflows on the fly you really
don't have to learn anything to make
this
but you know to basically ask questions
and a lot of information is already
provided as part of this platform and we
have already analyzed more than 150 000
individuals with almost uh
600 000 000 variation so it's a very
large data that we analyzed for this
project
now some of the things that i am not
discussing today but i would really
recommend you to go and read them
is that some many many times you will
actually hear that synonymous variations
the equation that do not change the
amino acid
will not have an impact on the disease
phenotype uh that is not true we
actually have shown in this work that it
actually can have disease association
impact
and second is since the data size that
we have now looking at is going to you
know by 2025 in another three years
the genomic data will bypass the data
that we generate on social media so now
you can imagine we are talking of
exabytes of data we have not even
talking of petabytes now
now that kind of data when you have you
don't not only have the challenge of
genotype phenotype correlation you also
have the challenge of analyzing and
handling this data and that is where we
developed frog again
it's not for discussion today
uh so basically what we are now doing
with all this computational platform you
might say what is the application of
this so the application is pretty
evident in 2016 the mitochondrial
medicine society actually recommended
next generation sequencing as the first
line of diagnosis for mitochondrial
diseases so it is not something that you
might do this is something which is a
highly recommended method to diagnose
mitochondrial diseases
and i am part of the clinical domain
working groups we are actually trying to
map every variation as per the uh
approved guidelines by acm acmg and amp
standards that we recommended
two years ago and were approved by kenji
and now we are working as a clinical
domains working group with a very large
team of clinicians to see how do we
actually translate this knowledge into a
clinical context
now my lab has been developing these
resources over a very long period of
time and we continue to do that from
different contexts now we are now trying
to see uh in one of our new projects is
how
pathogenic variations in mitochondria
make individuals more predisposed to
infections because the other vertical of
my lab work on infectious diseases so we
are now merging the two domains in in a
very logical context
now
i would like you to tell that why is
this important because these are
basically the four tenets of
personalized medicine personalized as in
you need to know how genetic variation
drives individual treatment it has to be
predictive
one should be able to identify what kind
of disease condition one is predisposed
to
it should be preventive if i know that
somebody is predisposed to diabetes at
the age of 30 there can be lifestyle
changes introduced and the person may
not manifest the disease at all
and it should be participatory like the
patient has to have informed choices and
take responsibility of their own health
now one thing that i would recommend all
of you to go back and check is the new
developments happening in precision
medicine
so we have evolved from the reference
human genome
as a reference to population specific
genomes to human and genomes because now
we know as and when we are sequencing
more and more human genomes there is
additional 4 to 5 million sites that are
getting added to the data sets which
means that we need to now capture the
complexity of human band genome with
respect to precision medicine if we have
to go anywhere forward from this point
onwards so have a look at the human pan
genomes progress that's something that
is very very recent and is still being
discussed on how do we really do it
there are recommendations but they are
still not implemented so this is
something which is an ongoing activity
so i would recommend any one of you who
who is interested in genomics
should be reading about this context
now i would like to basically take last
five minutes to before i close is to
tell you that genomics is not only about
personalized medicine and i'll give you
an example here
now kathleen falbeck actually was
imprisoned uh for killing all her four
babies right it's some of them it is
actually told said to be one of the most
horrific crimes that somebody can
perform
now the problem was that
scientific evidence so mayo clinic
pediatric cardiologist actually michael
ackerman and a team of scientists
linked the death of these babies to a
specific mutation which was leading to
sudden infant death syndrome
so this lady actually has not killed at
least two of her babies is that what
they could establish
for the other two they require data from
the father which was not available but
the whole point is that imagine uh
genetics actually freed this woman who
was convicted of killing her four babies
so genetics and precision medicine you
know this decision medicine is for
health but genetic genetics and genomics
in general have a wide array of
applications like even within our lab
which i have not told you today we
actually use it to understand emr
so there are a wide variety of
array of applications that you can think
of and these are all places where you
can probe as
you know as future prospects for your
career
now as i told you that my lab works on
two domains one is amr and the
antimicrobial register infections and
the other is mitochondrial diseases i
would like to show you something very
different in last two minutes that we
have done
so for some of you who does not
understand what antimicrobial resistance
is
so i'm actually shifting gears here so
there's no more genomics
from now onwards so i'm pretty sure all
of you know about the discovery of sir
alexander fleming
he discovered the first national
antibiotic penicillin and in his noble
speech nobel prize speech he actually
said that
if we don't take
penicillin or other antibiotics
carefully the bacteria will develop
resistance against these antibiotics and
they may no longer work now this was
something that he said in 1945
and this actually is coming out to be
true because now we are dealing with a
problem of antimicrobial resistance
it is a major issue i wanted all of you
to know about it it is called a silent
pandemic because we do not discuss it
the way we discuss covet but who has
declared amr as one of the top 10 global
public health threats facing humanity
today so it's a very major problem and
that is why we thought it is important
to sensitize younger generation about
the issue of amr because it cannot be
solved without participation from all of
us
and we also wanted that this
participation need not start when we are
already adults
what if we can explain this concept
to young children as young as 11 12
years old 13 years old can we explain a
very hard scientific concept to them in
a manner which allows them to change
behavior it is not just understanding
something it should influence
individuals in a manner where they are
able to change their action against
something which is not happening right
so i'll with the permission of
the organizers i would like to play a
one-minute video and i hope you enjoy it
this is basically a teaser for the game
so that you know what
the game actually talks about
i hope it works here we go
[Music]
just
so
[Music]
so
peace
[Music]
so this is a video and i thought
it's important for the community as you
know we are scientists so if it is a
problem that impacts all of us it's
something that we have to collectively
do and we are very happy that when we
developed this game it was it became one
of the finalists in the international
educational games competition
across the world so i would really like
all of you to go to the gyasa or my home
page and
play this game popularize it so that we
actually can contribute to the social uh
issue
which is amr it's not just a scientific
problem anymore
so
as mohit was saying i work with a very
very large group of people who are not
always sitting in my lab so i do a lot
of crowdsourcing projects and i work
with some brilliant kids they are doing
excellent uh work right now
these two kids happen to be my favorite
because they published in international
peer review journals from my lab when
they were still finishing their school
so they were very very young at that
point in time but extremely talented and
it actually what i could see in them as
talent was later endorsed by the fact
that puja became the gates cambridge
fellow
ashma became the gold's water scholar
and they both are on full scholarship
for their masters and phd programs
so this is a message to the students out
there we will be discussing more in the
panel
is that you don't need really an age or
a degree to do science uh passion is
what should drive you for doing
scientific discovery and i have i like
my experience with school kids it's
extremely rewarding in that context
a recommendation which i'll again
highlight in the panel is that be like a
space knife interdisciplinary
today if you are doing biology learn at
least one programming language very
strongly recommended the kind of data
that is being generated it will be
extremely difficult if you don't know
data analysis so do that
and with that i would like to conclude
my presentation for today by thanking my
lab members both in india and france and
i thank all the funding agencies who
have supported our lab over the years
i would also like to thank my institute
uh and i'm also happy and very proud to
tell you that we are among the top
four institutes worldwide who actually
contribute
to biological databases open source
biological databases to the world and
they are highly cited so this is a very
this is a proud thing for india because
we are actually in line with ebi and
ncbis i'm really really happy to share
that with all of you
uh we do some 3d printing not bio
printing in the lab so if some of you
are interested in doing that you're very
much welcome to come here and use this
device
and of course there are open phd and
postdoc positions in the lab so if any
one of you are interested and you saw a
brief of what my lab does if you need
more we can chat and take it forward
from there so with that thank you so
much again for having me and i'm happy
to take any questions